[Music]
from the studio that finally learned how
to make Pixar movies and the songwriting
duo behind hasa diga
a boy comes the feature-length music
video for let it go frozen it's been
three years since the last Disney
musical and eighteen years since the
last good is the musical now the Big D
is back and adjusted for inflation with
two princesses two goopy sidekicks and
three different orphans welcome to
arendelle a magical wish Scandinavian
niche country that's been cursed with
eternal winter even though their main
export his eyes meet Elsa a
manic-depressive princess with a
confusing set of powers like snow
blasting dressmaking castle building and
creating life your life think so they
kind of gloss over that one fall in love
with her adorable sister Anna who spends
three years of her adult life shut
inside a castle even though she could
leave at any time I can't live like this
anymore
hidden leaves and who could forget the
completely unnecessary unexplained
magical troll rocks when disaster
strikes watch Anna save the day by
teaming up with her sister a merchant a
hot guy and a snowman to defeat villains
like her sister a merchant a hot guy and
a snowman experience a clever twist on
past Disney films
teaches girls everywhere they don't need
a prince to rescue them because all men
are disgusting loners greedy murderers
or lying manipulative power-hungry
sociopaths you won't get away with this
I already have
happy now Jezebel so gather the family
and sing along on a musical journey
that's all about the soundtrack
featuring unforgettable songs like the
exposition saw the song that sounds like
it's from wicked
[Music]
[Applause]
for the first time in forever
it's as good as lime cane go romantic
you had
the other romantic duet I'm kinda turned
on by reindeer the anthropomorphic
sidekicks comic relief's off when you're
out of ideas you give on my singing the
one you skip we are cutting knives cuz
we are cutting the one you don't know
the words do and Yolo saw
[Music]
get it
[Applause]
[Music]
starring forgotten Sarah Marshall
Christoph Waltz ugly Smurfs hans gruber
merchandising and the wickedly talented
adele dazeem
frozen you don't need true love to thaw
a frozen heart just soak in the water
for a few hours
works on turkeys hey screen junkies
can't get enough of my buttery voice
then check out honest game trailers over
on Smosh games click the box to check
out our honest take on Mario Kart screw
you blue shells she got a big booty so I
call her big booty
shut up crime I'm a strong independent
woman who don't need no man if peeing
your pants is cool
consider me Miles Davis